- What we're going to do in this video
is talk about a special
class of random variables
known as binomial variables.
And as we will see as we build
up our understanding of them,
not only are they interesting
in their own right,
but there's a lot of very powerful
probability and statistics
that we can do based on our understanding
of binomial variables.
So to make things concrete
as quickly as possible,
I'll start with a very tangible example
of a binomial variable
and then we'll think a
little bit more abstractly
abut what makes it binomial.
So let's say that I have a coin.
This is my coin here.
It doesn't even have to be a fair coin.
Let me just draw this really fast.
So that's my coin.
And let's say on a
given flip of that coin,
the probability that I get
heads is zero point six
and the probability that I'd get tails,
well it'd be one minus zero point six
or zero point four.
And what I'm going to do
is I'm going to define
a random variable X
as being equal to the number
of heads
after
ten
flips
of my coin.
Now, what makes this a binomial variable?
Well, one of the first conditions
that's often given for a binomial variable
is that it's made up of a finite number
of independent trials.
So,
it's made up
made up of
independent
independent trials.
Now, what do I mean by independent trials?
Well, a trial is each flip of my coin.
So a flip
is equal to a trial
in the language of this
statement that I just made.
And what do I mean by each flip
or each trial being independent?
Well the probability of
whether I get heads or tails
on each flip
are independent of whether
I just got heads or tails
on some previous flip.
So, in this case, we are made up of
independent trials.
Now, another condition is
each trial can be clearly classified
as either a success or failure.
Or another way of thinking about it:
Each trial clearly has one
of two discreet outcomes.
So each trial,
and the example I'm giving,
the flip is a trial,
can be classified
classified
as
either
success
or failure.
So, in the context of
this random variable X,
we could define heads as a success
because that's what we
are happening to count up.
And so you're either going
to have success or failure.
You're either going to have heads or tails
on each of these trials.
Now another condition for
being a binomial variable
is that you have a fixed number of trials.
Fixed
number
of
trials.
So in this case,
we're saying that we have ten trials,
ten flips of our coin.
And then the last condition
is the probability
of success,
in this context success is a heads,
on each trial,
each trial,
is constant.
And we've already talked about it.
On each trial on each flip,
the probability of heads
is going to stay at zero point six.
If for some reason that were to change
from trial to trial,
maybe if you were to swap the coin
and each coin had a different probability
then this would no longer
be a binomial variable.
And so you might say,
"Okay, that's reasonable,
I get why this is a binomial variable.
Can you give me an example
of something that is not
a binomial variable?"
Well let's say that I were
to define the variable Y
and it's equal to the number of kings
after
taking
two cards
from
a standard deck of cards.
Standard deck.
Without replacement.
So you might immediately say,
"Well, this feels like
it could be binomial."
We have...each trial can be classified
as either a success or failure.
Each trial is when I take a card out.
If I get a king that looks
like that would be a success.
If I don't get a king
that would be a failure.
So it seems to meet that right over there.
It has a fixed number of trials.
I'm taking two cards out of the deck
so it seems to meet that.
But what about these conditions
that it's made up of independent trials
or that the probability
of success on each trial
is constant?
Well,
if I get a king
the probability of king
on the first trial,
probability I say king
on first trial
would be equal to, well,
out of a deck of 52 cards,
you're going to have four kings in it.
So the probability of a
king on the first trial
would be four out of 52.
But what about the
probability of getting a king
on the second
on the second trial?
What would this be equal to?
Well, it depends on what
happened on the first trial.
If the first trial you had a king,
well then you would have,
so let's see, this would be the situation
given first trial,
first king,
well now there would be three kings left
in a deck of 51 cards.
But if you did not get a
king on the first trial,
now you have four kings
in a deck of 51 cards
because, remember, we're
doing it without replacement.
You're just taking that
first card, whatever you did,
and you're taking it aside.
So what's interesting here is
this is not made up of independent trials.
It does not meet this condition.
The probability on your second trial
is dependent on what
happens on your first trial.
And another way to think about it
is because we aren't replacing
each card that we're picking,
the probability of success on each trial
also is not constant.
And so that's why this right over here
is not a binomial variable.
Now, if Y,
if we got rid of
without replacement
and if we said we did replace
every card after we picked it
then things would be different.
Then we actually would be
looking at a binomial variable.
So instead of without replacement
if I just said with replacement,
well then your probability
of a king on each trial
is going to be four out of 52.
You have a finite number of trials.
You're probability of success
is going to stay constant
and they would be independent.
And obviously each trial
could easily be classified
as either a success or a failure.